les pieds dans le sable et le beach
tennis se pratique en général en duo
mixte ou non mixtes sur un terrain de
beach volley avec un filet à 1 mètre 70
ou 1 m 82 auteur parapentiste donc
effectivement on est sur le sable donc
là pas de rebond possible on joue avec
des balles qui ressemble à bâle de mini
tennis et on a des raquettes voilà en
carbone fibre de verre qui font à peu
près 350 g c'est très physique où est
sûre long terme c'est quand même
physique en et sur le sable de
déplacement et quand même particulier ce
qui est génial c'est qu'on arrive aussi
à des plongeons quand on est en
difficulté
l'association paris ouest beach tennis
existe depuis février 2021 et compte
aujourd'hui une trentaine de licenciés
les membres de l'association cherchait
un lieu plus grand et à proximité pour
pratiquer ce sport c'est dur de trouver
des terrains aujourd'hui on a un seul
terrain qui est située sur moudon donc
du côté de deux sèvres et on le partage
avec le beach volley donc aujourd'hui on
est trente adhérents partagent avec le
beach volley autant dire que les canaux
sont très difficiles à trouver et ce qui
est vraiment frustrant c'est qu'on peut
pas jouer tous ensemble comme
aujourd'hui les terrains de beach tennis
n'étant pas encore aux normes ces
derniers seront bientôt agrandi à terme
l'association espère voir la
construction de quatre terrains
homologués pour pouvoir organiser des
tournois et des événements les terrains
là vous été mis à disposition
au travers d'une convention d'occupation
avec une transformation qui arrivera
sous peu puisque pour que les terrains
soient aux normes ils ont besoin d'être
légèrement agrandie par rapport à la
taille qu'ils ont la taille existantes
le beach tennis peut se pratiquer tout
au long de l'année été comme hiver
l'adhésion est de 60 euros pour l'année
et la licence pour la fédération
française de tennis est à 30 euros